oneovision's eighth episode did a lot to
explain the mystery at the heart of the
mcu series
namely why did wanda make herself the
center of a strange surreal sitcom
let's dig even deeper into some of the
easter eggs and references in wanda's
real-life tv
land in episode eight of wandavision
wanda is made to see the night that her
life was ripped apart in sokovia
moments before a fateful explosion she
and her family are watching her favorite
episode of the dick van dyke show
season two's it may look like a walnut
this is a classic episode of the series
as rob petry watches a science fiction
film about walnut obsessed aliens
infiltrating earth the next day
all the events of the film seem to come
true first his wife turns into a space
invader and then rob
himself begins to morph into an alien
the episode was a parody of the sci-fi
classic invasion of the body snatchers
only with the movie star danny thomas as
the extraterrestrial ringleader the
easter egg at play is that this dick van
dyke episode is really just a bad dream
rob's wife hasn't been taken by the
aliens he's not missing his thumbs or
lost his sense of humor
similarly wanda takes all of the bad
things that have ever happened to her
and turns him into a bad dream
thanks to agatha harkness wanda
experiences a vivid flashback of her
childhood in episode viii
and for the first time we see the
incident that radicalized wanda and
pietro and drove them toward joining
hydra
in the middle of tv night a missile rips
through their house killing their
parents
pietro grabs wanda and pulls her under
the bed keeping her safe but that's when
another missile lands three feet in
front of them but it doesn't go
off the siblings stay trapped under the
bed for two days before they move
and as the duo mention in avengers age
of ultron the rocket has a very familiar
word painted on the side
on the side of the shell let's paint it
one word
stark that spurs their hatred of tony
stark pushing them into the arms of
hydra as they volunteer for the
experiments that would give them their
powers
up until this episode however we'd only
heard of this tragic event but the scene
in one division goes into greater detail
including a reveal that the shell
actually said stark industries
more importantly agatha questions wanda
as to whether she ever wondered if it
was a coincidence that the bomb didn't
go off
did you stop that bomb what
used a probability hex from her
perspective it's obvious that wanda was
a baby witch who subconsciously used a
probability altering spell to prevent
the explosive from going off
during one of episode 8's flashback
sequences we see the mind stone float
out towards wanda
as a result she sees an image of a woman
in silhouette with flowing hair and a
headband very similar to the classic
scarlet witch costume
none of this is recorded by hydra's
cameras what exactly this is referring
to is unclear
is the mind stone seeing wanda's future
where she fully embraces her identity
as the scarlet witch or is it a
reference to her heritage
in the comics wanda learned only
relatively recently that her mother was
actually a natalia maximoff one in a
long line of scarlet witches could this
be true of wanda
whatever the case may be this is the
point that wanda first comes into her
powers
however it's also clear from the start
that she's never had a good grip on how
she's able to do what she does ascribing
all of it to the mind stone's influence
it may well be that the mind stone
simply unlocked her own innate abilities
after touching the mind stone wanda sits
down to watch an episode of the brady
bunch
in this particular installment cindy
brady is having an argument with her
brother bobby about her beloved doll
as for the plot of that particular brady
bunch episode the doll goes missing and
cindy blames bobby
the young boy professes his innocence
and their argument spills over into the
rest of the family before the real
culprits their dog
is revealed that episode is a subtle
reminder that things aren't always as
they seem and we can often overlook the
real culprits and create undeserved
blame if we're not
careful in other words wanda is being
blamed for certain things that she
hasn't done
and agatha is gleefully stringing her
along the episode also has a slightly
more obvious connection to wandavision
the doll that the vision uses to
practice changing diapers on in episode
3 is an exact
duplicate to that doll in episode 8
wanda has a flashback to the moment she
visited sword headquarters
in this heartbreaking scene she's led to
the vision's body and allowed to examine
it
i can't feel you wanda's line is a
callback to the vision's last words to
her in avengers infinity war
after agreeing to destroy vision to keep
his infinity stone away from thanos
vision tells her
you could never hurt me i just feel you
wanda revisiting that line in sword hq
is a sad acknowledgement to the end of
their connection
in episode 8's post-credits scene sword
director tyler hayward reveals that his
team has had a breakthrough
they've powered up the dead vision's
body using energy channeled from an
object directly affected by wanda's
magic
as it turns out all hayward has wanted
all along as a way to revive and control
the sentient weapon
this revived vision is a ghostly white a
direct reference to a period in the
comics when vision was torn apart and
then put back together by henry pym
during the late 80s
in the comics the ghostly barefoot
vision was drained of all emotions for
years
which led to more than a few super
villain plots will the same hold true
for vision 2.0 or will it all tie up in
a happy ending like the plots on wanda's
favorite tv shows
a silly mission that always becomes fine
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one